[Musique]
et
bonjour nouvelle saison de pourvu que ça
dure les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat avec
aujourd'hui une émission spéciale sur la
crise énergétique que nous traversons
beaucoup de questions se posent
maintenant que la russie a quasiment
fermé le robinet du gaz risque de
pénurie coupures de courant chasse au
gaspillage on parle de tout ça avec vous
à l'espagnol une hachette bonjour
bonjour merci d'être là avec tout sur
public sénat ministre de la transition
énergétique pardon avec cette question
quand même d'emblée je vais vous la
posez c'est un scénario noir extrait
mais il est sur toutes les lèvres si les
planètes se déshabille n'y signalent à
la russie cesse définitivement de nous
livrer du gaz s'y fait très très froid
s'il verrait est rude et rigoureux si
edf n'arrivent pas à redémarrer toutes
ses centrales nucléaires si on ne fait
pas les 10% d'économies d'énergie voulue
par le gouvernement les français les
entreprises à se faire publier que se
passe-t-il y at-il ou n'y aura-t-il pas
de coupure de courant d'abord ce que je
veux dire c'est que il n'y a pas de
risque de black out dans le sens qu'on
l'entend c'est à dire le black out c'est
l'électricité qui s'arrête et on ne sait
pas la redémarrer parce qu'il ya eu une
un problème de tension dans le système
ça nous avons anticipé et nous avons des
implants pour faire face donc ça on
exclut donc ce qui est arrivé dans
certains pays où tout d'un coup vous ça
s'arrête de manière non anticipée qui
m'arrive c'est pas le rétablir c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui ne concerne
pas notre pays ni a priori nos voisins
la deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
qu'en revanche la situation est sérieuse
et je crois que tout le monde l'aura
compris lorsque vous avez le principal
fournisseur de gaz naturel et de
carburant qui décide de réduire
s'agissant du gaz ses approvisionnements
lorsque nous mêmes nous nous
désengageons de l'approvisionnement en
carburant il faut faire un plan et nous
l'avons fait et ce plan doit nous
permettre de couvrir au maximum ses
fournitures 40% du gaz 50 % du carburant
au niveau européen donc pas de black out
total mais ce qu'on peut imaginer des
coupures encore une fois localisé entre
18 heures et 20 heures en cas de pics de
froid si vraiment il est moins 10 mans
15 en france pour soulager ou encore une
fois le réseau et éviter le black out
total 100 pas imaginer ça c'est ça ce
sont des scénarios qui que les français
connaissent vous savez que quand il ya
un incendie une installation qui fait
rend à qui conduit à avoir un problème
sur le réseau des scénarios de délestage
existe ce sont des scénarios
effectivement pendant deux heures
certains postes de distribution sont
coupées la plus généralisée mais ce dont
nous parlons aujourd'hui et un plan que
nous préparons avec le gouvernement
depuis plusieurs mois et qui nous permet
de faire face
à la crise alors quel est ce plan le
premier le premier élément c'est de
faire en sorte de remplacer gaz russe
qui nous manquent par autre chose nous
avons accéléré
l'approvisionnement nos terminaux
méthaniers il fonctionnait pas à plein
avant une fonctionne aujourd'hui à 100%
et nous importons du gaz naturel
liquéfié qui le guette russie france
étaient 17% nous importerons 40% pour
toute l'europe 17 % pour la france aime
à penser 9 et maintenance et 9 enfin
c'est une oeuvre pour cent le niveau de
dépendance mais on la réduit de moitié
tout à fait tout à fait et aujourd'hui
surtout couru de gens plus de gaz qui
vient de la norvège plus de gaz qui
vient dans nos terminaux méthaniers et
cela nous a permis de remplir nos
stockages de gaz
stratégique à 100% c'est à dire 20 90 et
quelques pourcents c'est à dire avec
deux mois d'avancé par rapport à notre
objectif de remplissage de gaz l'effet
stocks de gaz on sait que ça ne
représente que 20 à 30 % notre
consommation élevée de gaz dans la
moitié consommait d'ailleurs l'hiver
donc en fait présente 50 % du gaz que
nous consommons sur une saison d'hiver à
et nous en avons besoin l'hiver puisque
le reste de l'année nous pouvons nous
contenter d'avoir les terminaux
méthaniers qui fonctionne et pendant
l'hiver évidemment les terminaux
méthaniers vont continuer à fonctionner
et le gmail faut expliquer c'est du
jeunesse et du gaz naturel liquéfié
exactement car il ya des méthaniers
c'est ça et qui arrivent avec des
méthaniers qui regazéifié de transformer
en gaz donc ça coûte un peu plus cher
que du gaz qui arrive directement
et qui ensuite est injecté dans nos
réseaux de même que la norvège fourni à
la france mais comme point d'entrée de
l'europe du gaz n'a directement gazeux
et qui est rentré dans notre système
gazeux et qui permet de fournir la
france est de fournir une partie de
leurs restes de l'or donc se faire
remplacer le gaz russe c'est donc
essentiellement le gaz norvégien le gnl
voilà américain socialement non pas
essentiellement américains c'est assez
diversifié il ya huit pays qui
fournissent à titre principal
ce gaz qui viennent de la façade
américaine et de pays d'afrique
quelques pays ou ayant essentiellement
de pays d'afrique je veux pas dire de
bêtises et nous avons également les
interconnexions qui fonctionne et donc
l'espagne qui est en capacité de fournir
du gaz naturel en tant que de besoin que
l'espagne elle même a du gaz importé par
méthaniers et dispose de connexions dont
par gazoduc donc pas de pénurie de gaz à
vous écouter en temps quand on écoute la
diarrhée général adjoint jihadi pour
l'hiver prochain on a les volumes de gaz
nécessaire à climat moyen à privas
moyens oui tout à fait alors c'est là où
il faut rentrer un petit peu dans le
détail c'est à dire que maintenant ce
sur quoi nous travaillons c'est d'abord
un scénario pour passer l'ensemble de
l'hiver avec nos stocks les importations
et de faire face à toute la consommation
de gaz que nous utilisons tout au long
d'un hiver sur un père et un scénario
comme l'année dernière par exemple
évidemment on n'a pas de difficulté
depuis le début d'année un certain
nombre d'économies de gaz ont été faites
si nous prolongerons cette économie de
gaz nous n'avons pas de difficulté même
si donc notre consommation de gaz a
baissé assez significativement et vous
savez que nous visons 10 % de baisse de
notre consommation de gaz ce qui se
passe au niveau cet hiver nous passons
l'hiver sans jali dire sans difficulté
quand bien même le climat ne viendrais
froid là où c'est plus compliqué c'est
si nous avons des pics de froid où il
faudra effectivement dans ce cas faire
des efforts complémentaires parce que un
pic de froid c'est pas juste réinjecter
un peu de gaz tous les jours par nos
méthaniers et par nos stockages de gaz
mais c'est un
mobilisation de consommation et par
rapport à ça nous avons préparé un plan
donc pas seulement sur
l'approvisionnement en électricité et en
gaz puisque je vous ai parlé
d'approvisionnement on est en gaz
l'approvisionnement en électricité c'est
les interconnexions que nous avons avec
l'allemagne avec l'espagne avec la
belgique avec le royaume uni qui nous
fournissent de l'électricité dans leurs
rangs du jazz nous fournissent
l'électricité exactement et alors on
vend du gaz à l'allemagne mais ils nous
fournissent de l'électricité les autres
pays n'ont pas besoin de nous en moyenne
pour le gaz et cette électricité nous
permet de venir en appui dans une saison
normale on importe une vingtaine de
jours de l'électricité depuis les pays
européens à l'espagnol une hache et à la
proche de l'hiver vous êtes plus
d'inquiétude pour le réseau électrique
ou pour notre approvisionnement en gaz
ou est-ce que vous êtes totalement
sereine en fait
l'électricité et le gaz sont liés c'est
à dire que le gaz que nous envoyons en
allemagne leur permettent de produire
l'électricité qu'ils nous renvoient rhin
et donc il faut bien connecté ces deux
enjeux ne pas imaginer que l'un est
indépendant de l'autre ce qui est clair
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons tous
les leviers à activer pour faire face un
problème de gaz et que s'agissant de
l'électricité nous savons d'expérience
que les derniers hivers nous avons pu
compter sur la production d'électricité
de nos voisins et que du coup il est
important que ils puissent eux-mêmes
avoir le gaz qui leur permettent de nous
fournir l'électricité et d'exporter
l'électricité vers nous alors ce qu'il
faut rappeler c'est con à 24 de nos
cinquante six réacteurs nucléaires qui
sont en service 32 sont à l'arrêt pour
des causes de maintenance ou des preuves
de corrosion est ce que vous avez ou pas
d'ailleurs la garantie que des f sera en
mesure de redémarrer suffisamment de
réacteurs pour passer l'hiver à ce que
beaucoup d'experts nous disent d'un an
il y aura au moins une dizaine de
réacteurs qui seront à l'arrêt cet hiver
alors qu edf s'est engagé à les
redémarrer quelle visibilité vous avez
cette visibilité à les partager
accessible à tous avec figurent
notamment sur le site de rte c'est à
dire que
légalement tout producteur d'électricité
doit communiquer quand est-ce qu'ils
arrêtent et quand est-ce qu'il redémarre
une infrastructure de production et donc
cette information est disponible elle
correspond à la meilleure connaissance
de l'opérateur et edf effectivement a
donné cette information et indique que
les réacteurs qui sont aujourd'hui
arrêtés ont vocation à être redémarré
lundi si la famille vert après pour les
français c'est vrai que l'on dit on à 30
de nos réacteurs qui tombe en carafe par
me dire comme ça au plus mauvais moment
et là on dit mais quelle part de
responsabilité à la fois pour le
président d'edf quitte un président
sortant mais aussi pour le pouvoir en
place depuis 2010 alors c'est pour ça
que je voulais revenir sur la notion de
maintenance et que c'est pas 32
réacteurs qui seront en carafe
aujourd'hui c'est 32 réacteurs dont qui
passent leur contrôle technique pour
nous dire avec des mots
approchant ce dont vous savez quand vous
passez votre contrôle technique quand
vous avez fait le bon nombre de
kilomètres faut passer au contrôle
technique et les contrôles techniques
ont été positionnés aux bornes de
l'hiver justement pour avoir le maximum
de réacteur qui tourne cet hiver donc
c'est pour ça que nous sommes en fin
d'été on a un maximum de réacteurs qui
sont arrêtés pour pouvoir mieux
redémarrer cet hiver et en fin d'hiver
on va avoir des réacteurs qui
séquentiellement les uns derrière les
autres vont s'arrêter pour passer les
maintenant ce qu'ils ont à dire
c'est un processus qui est complexe qui
est industriel qui je dirais correspond
à une véritable
véritable savoir faire dont dispose et
df donc pas de mauvaises surprises à
attendre de ce qu'on dirait donc de ce
point de vue là je dirais que c'est la
qualité opérationnel d'edf c'est aussi
comme toujours vous pouvez avoir des
aléas sur une réparation vous pouvez
soit les plus vite aller moins vite ça
c'est un classique est ce que doit nous
dire edf s'est à chaque fois quand ils
ont l'information de bien ajuster ce
calendrier pour qu'on ait le maximum de
prévisibilité sur la saison ce qui est
particulier c'est d'avoir douze que
réacteurs qui sont ceux qui ont des
traces de corrosion ça c'est quelque
chose qui est nouveau ça ne rentre pas
dans la maintenance habituel c'est un
phénomène qui n'a pas été repéré sur
d'autres installations nucléaires dans
le monde edf a préparé un protocole de
réparation alors en soit c'est pas
inquiétant puisque le protocole d'europe
réparation enlève les pièces qui ont ces
traces de corrosion et remplace par des
pièces nouvelles donc il n'y a pas de
problème de sécurité l'hiver est plus
rude que prévu et ce que vous pourriez
redémarrer or ouvrir une ou deux
centrales à charbon si vraiment c'était
nécessaire on s'en est donné les moyens
ça fait partie du plan dans le plan
je vous en fait depuis le mois de
février un travail et à ses différents
leviers les stockages de gaz c'est une
décision que nous avons porté aussi au
niveau européen nous étions seuls pays à
avoir des stockages de gaz stratégique
depuis 2018 c'est une décision du
président de la république nous avons
obtenu que l'ensemble des pays européens
déstockage de gaza date de mai nous
avons passé une mois en juillet pour
permettre
d'avoir
la capacité à
prolonger une centrale à charbon qui
devait fermer cette année qui sera
prolongée d'une année qui la centrale de
saint-avold la centrale de cordemais
elle ne devait pas fermée mais nous
l'autorisent on a exploité
éventuellement c'est évidemment en cas
de besoin à exploiter plus longuement
un plus grand nombre d'heures à être
exploité à un plus grand nombre d'heures
nous avons également prévu à un projet
additionnel de terminal méthanier
flottant au havre et nous avons qu'il
sera pas faciliter les autorisations
donc celui ci sera prêt en septembre
2009 23 parce que il faut percer à
l'hiver prochain l'hiver 23 24 donc nous
sommes déjà en position de préparer
l'hiver 23 24 et
nous sommes donnés aussi les moyens de
réquisitionner éventuellement les
centrales à gaz sommes donné les moyens
de recenser l'ensemble des groupes
électrogènes diesel pour être prêt à
commander à ceux qui en disposent de
basculer sur un groupe électrogène
plutôt que d'utiliser l'électricité du
réseau dont vous voyez tous les leviers
sont aujourd'hui utilisés et nous
organisons un plan en cas de difficultés
mais comme c'est notre mission de le
faire par rapport à une crue décennale
une crue centenaire nous devons avoir un
plan de continuité d'activité activable
dans tous les scénarios et notre
scénario de référence je dirais c'est
celui de l'hiver 2010 2011 qui a été
levé vers le plus froid de ces vingt
dernières années et sur le sur lequel 14
étaient effectivement savoir si si on
prend telle mesure qu est ce que ça nous
donne comme confort supplémentaire si on
donne comme confort complémentaires pour
avoir les leviers en place au moment
d'aider des pics de consommation via ce
plan de sobriété énergétique réduire
collectivement de 10% notre consommation
d'énergie vous comptez autant sur les
entreprises que sur les français parce
qu'on dit que levier plus puissant pour
organiser un petit peu les économies
d'énergie ça reste comme de passer par à
les bâtiments les entreprises je vais
très clair le plan sobriété des
entreprises s'est pas l'état qui va
expliquer à quelle heure on éteint la
lumière à quelle heure on l'a rallumé
qu'elle doit être l'intensité de la
lumière dont elle bureau ou dans tel
atelier parce que les entreprises les
organisations syndicales les salariés
les équipes de management savent mieux
que nous ce qui est utile et ce qui met
moins ce qui correspond à
des économies où on fait la chasse au
gaspi et ce qui correspond à des
économies on risque d'aller trop loin
par rapport en termes de conditions de
travail des salariés ou en termes de
production le plan sobriété c'est pas
une baisse de la production ça ça doit
être très clair pour tout le monde c'est
vraiment être attentif au chauffage à
l'éclairage à l'utilisation de l'eau
chaude sanitaire est là on est dans une
sobriété qui vise à réduire notre
empreinte carbone la nuit vous l'avez
compris si l'électricité est allumé on
aura pas de problème d'approvisionnement
mais nous ce qui nous intéresse dans le
plan sobriété c'est un objectif
climatique c'est une transformation de
nos comportements nous nous sommes
engagés en 2050 à être une neutralité
carbone et dans tous les scénarios de
réseau du transport
d'électricité dans l'entreprise rte qui
a travaillé deux ans sur des scénarios
de décarbonation il ya un objectif de
diminution de 40% notre consommation
d'énergie à usage égal c'est à dire que
par exemple vous dans ses locaux en 2050
vous devez trouver les voies et moyens
en faisant la même activité de consommer
ou d'émettre d'arriver à zéro carbone
des missions et donc vous allez devoir
économiser 40 % d'énergie en faisant la
même chose et ça vous avez deux leviers
changer votre comportement
c'est à dire peut-être vous dire que
vous avez besoin de moins de luminosité
et puis utiliser des technologies qui
sont qui émettent moins de carbone
passer d'une lente normale à du led vous
allez économiser 60 % de consommation
sur les entreprises bercy a recensé de
1300 entreprises industrielles qui sont
des grosses consommatrices de gaz est ce
que vous savez madame anne manière une à
chelsea quelles sont celles qui seront
mises à contribution
quelles sont les entreprises qui seront
au contraire sanctuary the air ou encore
de la visibilité dessus alors ça c'est
un travail que nous menons avec
l'ensemble des filières j'ai réuni avec
roland lescure en juillet dernier
l'ensemble des filières pour leur
présenter la situation c'est-à-dire à la
fois la sobriété pour kouassi est utile
pourquoi ça contribue à un objet notre
objectif de décarbonation et ses
incontournables mais pourquoi ça peut
être aussi un levier très utile est
organisée pour faire face à l'hiver et
nous avons des discussions qui se
poursuivent avec les entreprises qui
utilisent beaucoup de gaz pour voir
comment elles sont capables de diminuer
leur consommation de gaz alors là au
coeur de leurs processus et de faire en
sorte qu'elle n'est pas à interrompre
leur activité avec des contrats
d'effacement c'est ce qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure alors pas seulement parce
que imaginer que ces coupures de gaz
d'électricité pour vont entraîner des
pertes pour ces entreprises qui pourront
nous ne pourrons pas les encaisser alors
la vraie question c'est comment on est
organisée pour faire ça ce des
entreprises qui s'arrête entre noël et
jour de l'an ou des entreprises qu'ils
arrêtent de produire au moment des
congés d'été il y en a beaucoup et donc
toutes les entreprises sont pas en
production continue la difficulté par
rapport à cet enjeu d'utilisation du gaz
c'est l'anticipation c'est à dire que si
on était sur un scénario où deux heures
avant ou les prévient en disant
attention on arrête le gaz
là la possibilité de s'organiser par
rapport à leurs salariés par rapport à
leurs clients par rapport à laval et au
site il pour lequel elles doivent
fournir des pièces qui elles mêmes sont
nécessaires pour la production d'autres
d'autres entreprises est évidemment
complexe donc notre enjeu c'est
d'anticiper au maximum de tenir compte
aussi du fait que certains sites de
production ont besoin d'être ne peuvent
pas s'arrêter du jour au lendemain ça
c'est très clair que ça peut abîmer
l'outil de production c'est le cas de
four un four pour produire des objets en
verre si vous l'interrompent et trop
rapidement vous ne pouvez plus utiliser
le four c'est des dizaines voire des
centaines de millions d'euros de casse
donc ça ce n'est pas possible
est ce que vous estimez demandé un gros
effort un effort colossal aux français
en augmentant de baisser leur
consommation d'énergie de 10 % angie
nous a dit que les français avaient
commencé à hauteur de 4 5 % c'était
à la fin de l'été et je suis retombé sur
cette étude opinionway qui est d'être un
petit peu un set 2016 mais qui montre
que 56% des français avaient froid
l'hiver malgré d'utilisation de leur
chauffage c'est difficile de leur
demander un effort supplémentaire alors
il ya évidemment une grande différence
entre deux catégories de français vous
avez 12 millions de français qui sont
dans une situation de précarité
énergétique ces 12 millions de français
ils vont pas baisser le chauffage ont la
bonne et simple raison qu'ils ont déjà
pc et qu'aujourd'hui notre combat pour
eux c'est de faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent remonter leur chauffage ou
qu'ils puissent vivre dans des
conditions de température qui soit
confortable et vous savez que en gros
l'idée c'est que 19 degrés c'est la
bonne température de chauffage c'est
celle qui figure aujourd'hui dans les
textes de loi
vous savez qu'il ya une température de
consigne qui a été précisé mais sa date
depuis des années qu'ils fixent cette
température à 19 degrés et que quelqu'un
qui ne peut pas dépasser 15 degrés qui
fut nommé un tout petit peu son
chauffage
évidemment on ne vit pas dans de bonnes
conditions beaucoup de français nous
disent ça c'est des enquêtes d'opinions
assez récente que eux ils sont prêts à
faire un effort sur leur consommation
d'énergie pour trois raisons la première
c'est que ils sont sensibilisés aux
enjeux de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
la deuxième c'est que ils ont entendu
qu'il y avait un problème de passage le
pivert et là ils disent d'accord mais à
condition que les autres fassent des
efforts et en particulier les grandes
entreprises et en particulier les
administrations c'est pour ça que nous
avons pris les devants que nous
souhaitons être exemplaire sur le sujet
des économies d'énergie puis la
troisième raison elle est très concrète
c'est que c'est leur pouvoir d'achat
s'il arrive à faire des économies c'est
autant d'argent en plus sur leur compte
en banque et nous allons lancer une
campagne grand public sur cinq gestes
essentiels qui sont vraiment les gestes
je dirais gagnant gagnant en termes de
confort est gagnant
en baisse d'un degré en baisse de la
consommation d'énergie savoie la chance
que ça baisse d'un degré de votre choix
vous réglez votre chauffage à 19 degrés
si vous étiez avancé 7 % de gain
d'énergie alors c'était moyenne 1
évidemment vous vous coupez les intérêts
les appareils en veille c'est
relativement nouveau c'est beaucoup de
gains d'énergie
c'est également vous réglez votre
chauffe-eau il faut que votre
chauffe-eau un technicien passe sur que
il fonctionne parfaitement et pour une
maintenance assez régulière à peu près
tous les ans et on a des gains d'énergie
de 10 de 15% et qu'il soit bien réglée à
la bonne température 55 degrés
c'est également des économies sur le
déplacement de votre machine afin du
moment vous faites tourner votre machine
à laver 18 ans wozzeck voilà vos
équipements qui sont le plus
consommateur ben si on peut le déplacer
en mettant après 20 heures ou avant 8
heures du matin le grille pain avant 8
heures du matin ça peut être un gain
d'énergie en tout cas ça soulage le
réseau et surtout si vous jouez sur des
tarifs de type core plein creux c'est
aussi un gain de pouvoir d'achat vous
misez sur la responsabilité sur la bonne
volonté des français qui peuvent le
faire vu l'urgence il fallait pas passer
par des mesures certaines obligatoire je
sais qu'on peut pas après contrôle et
chez tous les français à température de
la maison non nous travaillons en fait
avec les acteurs du logement
dans les groupes de travail sobriété il
y en a neuf aujourd'hui il y en a un qui
porte sur tous les gestionnaires de
logements que ce soit les syndics
d'immeubles dont vous savez qu'en fait
ils ont souvent la main sur les
installations de chauffage est rarement
vous vous posez la question de la
température de consigne à ses fans c'est
pas une question vous avez en assemblée
générale de copropriété règle générale
ce qui se passe c'est que la personne
qui gère le chauffage de votre immeuble
règle puis quelqu'un dans l'immeuble
appel en disant j'ai un peu froid est-ce
qu'on pourrait augmenter le chauffage
mais cette discussion en a rarement lieu
entre les personnes qui occupe le
logement que ce soit le l'immeuble que
ce soit des locataires ou que ce soit
des propriétaires donc là l'idée c'est
de faire en sorte de s'appuyer sur les
professionnels qui gèrent de l'habitat
collectif alors évidemment ça concerne
pas l'habitat individuel mais l'habitat
collectif dont on avait quand même
beaucoup
ger l'habitat collectif et qui puisse
aider et accompagner les locataires les
propriétaires dans une bonne gestion de
leur chauffage et qui puisse leur
renvoyer aussi les économies ça je pense
que tout le monde aura intérêt à agir
dans cette direction nous travaillons
aussi sur des coups de pouce qui
permettra qui rendent intéressant le
fait d'installer un thermostats
intelligents chez soi qui rendent
intéressant le fait d'avoir une gestion
technique des bâtiments c'est à dire
pilotés à distance et pas de devoir
faire passer un technicien à chaque fois
que vous modifiez le chauffage ou l'eau
chaude sanitaire c'est tous ces éléments
là qui sont sur le papier des toutes
petites décisions mais qui peuvent faire
une grande différence encore une fois on
mesure aujourd'hui que vous avez
beaucoup de chauffage collectif qui sont
plutôt positionné à 21 degrés
aujourd'hui
ça fait une grosse baisse de la
consommation énergétique c'est une
baisse sur la facture et c'est une
baisse de nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre ménard questions sur le
télétravail est ce que c'est une mesure
ou pas efficaces pour réduire notre
consommation d'énergie les yeux l'agent
saint-etienne d'énergie nous dit oui
s'il est mis en place trois jours par
semaine vous pensé pourquoi pas le
rendre obligatoire serti cet hiver
sachant que le medef clairement s'est
positionné contre en disant que le
télétravail pour qu'il soit 7 efficaces
sur le plan énergétique uniquement quand
les bureaux sont complètement fermés
c'est que c'est un peu frappé sous du
bon sens et voilà donc en fait le
télétravail ne peut contribuer à des
économies d'énergie que si on a pensé à
la fois comment ça se passe dans
l'habitat des gens qui télétravaillent
c'est à dire 'est-ce qu'il rajoute
est-ce qu'ils sont en habitat individuel
est ce qu'ils doivent rallumer leur
chaudière allumer leur chauffage quand
il rentre à la maison et de l'autre côté
comment ça se passe dans l'immeuble qui
ne seraient plus occupé si
c'est un télétravail ou les gens
ne sont pas tous on peut pas fermer le
bâtiment est grand temps qu elle chauffe
et ça malheureusement ça n'a pas
d'impact sur le chauffage si c'est un
télétravail qui est pensé organiser avec
les oliviers et qui fait en fait ça va
dépendre des entreprises certaines
entreprises ont aujourd'hui sont assez
avancés ils sont en capacité de dire je
peux le faire parce que j'ai trois jours
entre le week-end et un jours de
télétravail sur lequel j'ai le soutien
de mes salariés et dans ce cas là c'est
trois jours où je peux vraiment fermé le
chauffage en tout cas diminuer le
chauffage et l'électricité et j'ai des
gros gars et puis vous avez des
organisations qui le disent mais j'ai
toujours besoin d'avoir une équipe parce
qu'il peut avoir des urgences et des
appels d'offres les appels d'offres
malheureusement il n'y a pas de week-end
pour des appels d'offres et donc je vais
toujours devoir mettre à disposition les
locaux et si j'aimais met à disposition
les locaux je vais pas arrêter le
chauffage je vais pas arrêter
l'électricité et à la fin mai mais gain
d'énergie sont relativement minimes bon
ce qu'on retiendra qu'entretient c'est
pour passer cet hiver il va falloir
tourner fasse un effort entreprises
particules ou le monde s'y met je crois
que la grande conclusion elle est double
c'est un on est préparé et on a beaucoup
de levier qui ont été activés dans notre
boîte à outils deux comparses comprendra
et on anticipera chacun à notre niveau
évidemment les grandes organisations et
j'appelle les grandes organisations vers
les 30 entreprises les collectivités
locales aussi ont un rôle essentiel à
jouer plus nous on sera capable
d'organiser la sobriété énergétique
plus ce sera facile le passé cet hiver
les des mesures contraignantes et c'est
vraiment d'objectif en cours voilà c'est
vraiment notre objectif avec la première
ministre et le président la république
c'est de compter sur le fait que chacun
à notre niveau on a quelque chose enfin
on a les leviers pour diminuer notre
consommation d'énergie encore une fois
ça ne concerne pas les plus précaires
les plus précaires notre enjeu c'est au
contraire de les sortir de leur
passoires thermiques et de faire en
sorte qu enfin il trouve du confort dans
leur maison et mieux mieux on sera à
ramer si on fait cette sobriété
énergétique pour passer l'hiver prochain
allez merci de passer nous voir
allemagne espagne et une hache et merci
beaucoup ministre de la transition
énergétique merci à vous et puis pq cd
voilà les missions qui rend les
co-responsables c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui émissions magazines à voir
ou revoir sur public sénat le replay je
vous le rappelle c'est publicsenat.fr
rendez vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]